la ciudad turca de izmir la tercera
mayor ciudad de turquía ha quedado
severamente afectada esta tarde por el
terremoto de 6 como ha ocurrido a pocos
kilómetros de sus costas el epicentro de
este terremoto ha ocurrido justo delante
de las costas de la isla griega de samos
que se ha visto sin embargo menos
afectada que las costas de kirchner
pensamos tan solo ha colapsado el techo
de una iglesia ortodoxa mientras que en
izmir 20 edificios según el gobierno
turco han quedado completamente
destrozados y es en ellos ahora mismo
donde se concentran las tareas de
rescate de posibles sobrevivientes y de
personas que hayan podido fallecer
en este terremoto a turquía tiene aún
muy viva en la memoria el terremoto de
1999 hace 21 años cuando en smith una
ciudad muy cerca de estambul murieron en
un terremoto en una sola noche 17.000
personas 250.000 se quedaron sin sus
hogares turquía tiene el problema de
estar en una falla tectónica
completamente constante en su actividad
lo que provoca que haya casi anualmente
terremotos algunos de los cuales son
casi imperceptibles otros pueden ser
tragedias como la que estamos
ahora mismo cada año mueren varias
decenas de personas por terremotos y la
última fue en este pasado enero en el
sureste de turquía donde treinta y pico
personas murieron en un terremoto en la
provincia de elazig la oposición se
queja de que el país aún muchos años
después de haber pasado grandes
tragedias sigue sin poder estar
preparada para otros eventos como este